all of the talk of loyalty and and
political loyalty and stuff I'm I'm like
I don't understand I guess the
perspective of the people that are that
appreciate monarchy or that want it and
like I a lot of I'm like yo yo in
England like down with the monarchy like
let's start let's start a Democratic
Republic in England let's do it Now's
the Time do in Thailand let's do the
monarchy in the monarchy in England like
they don't actually have any like
significant legislative power and
they're a net benefit uh to the economy
but the kinge the king can disband part
yeah the uh and the King approves the
royal family approves the Prime Minister
I
think I think it would be be naive to
assume that when the what was it the
Civil War in the UK I'm not big on UK
but they like Civil War and then they're
like okay okay okay we got to we got to
split power and create the House of
Commons and let people have some say in
this yeah all that was was the king
being like how do we prevent a
revolution where we get our heads
chopped off